on vous parlait lundi de cette garderie
de tout neuf à saint bruno de
montarville qu'ils ne pouvaient pas
ouvrir comme prévu quelques jours
quelques jours en raison d'un gel des
subventions décrétée par québec
or devant le tollé des parrains québec
fait volte face comme nous le dit david
gentilles et après quelques jours d'une
sorte de moratoire la ministre de la
famille recul et je suis fier de vous
annoncer que les travaux commencent vous
rassurer les familles du québec les gens
qui sont en projet peuvent continuer à
travailler
tout est relancé les quelques 6300
places prévues pour cette année seront
ouvertes tel que planifié
ça a été vraiment une joie ce matin
d'apprendre seul ici ou l'ouverture
prévue le 16 juin semblait menacée
l'annnonce de québec arrive à point
aussi pour eve des bébés elle est placée
ils se font rares donc une place à la
pouponnière ce son qui on est très
content le gouvernement affirme avoir
décidé après analyse des chiffres
le québec peut se payer parce que je
vais le dire comme ça
ce qui s'en vient cette année dans le
réseau on estime que la ministre
charbonneau n'avait simplement pas le
choix
par contre on va rester vigilant pour la
suite parce que y'a rien qui garantie
d'un moment non plus que les projets en
développement qui était pas aussi
avancée pour les prochaines années vont
pouvoir se concrétiser
on fait ce qu'on veut d'autres pensent
que le gouvernement a raison de vouloir
réfléchir avant d'autoriser les places
pour les prochaines années il faut
prendre un temps d'arrêt
c'est correct et 2,0 kick des quelle
manière on peut offrir aux enfants aux
parents du québec des places de qualité
le plus rapidement possible l'opposition
répète qu'il faut hausser les tarifs et
affirme que le gouvernement a manqué de
transparence le fait qu'ils se soient
campé dans un arrêt des projets pendant
deux jours ça démontre qu'ils aient
qu'ils avaient mal évalué
le débat et les attentes des parents on
promet toujours au final 28 mille places
supplémentaires pour compléter le réseau
mais à partir de l'an prochain
ces places pourraient être créés un peu
plus tard qu'on avait prévu au départ
ici d'habitude il est râpeux canada et
on va se rendre justement saint bruno de
montarville jacques on a parlé lundi
les gens étaient découragés n'en
revenais pas fait de cette décision
gouvernementale
or au boisé enchanté cette fameuse
garderie qu'est devenu le symbole de ces
plages lyon doit être content
aujourd'hui
ouais je soulage évidemment patrice la
propriétaire de cette garderie n'en
reviens pas d'abord de ce changement
rapide du côté gouvernemental
mais il se dit maintenant tellement
heureuse rose à bord pour elle patrice
parce qu'il faut rappeler qu'elle
investit près de deux millions de
dollars pour construire cette nouvelle
garderie à saint bruno et heureuse aussi
et surtout pour les parents
j'ai été inondé d'appels de courriels de
messages de texte aux mêmes et donc les
parents il m'a en fait est que je pense
que s'ils croient vraiment tout de suite
donc on va devoir la dans les prochaines
minutes
les rassure et envoyer des courriels en
eau parole pour confirmer la nouvelle et
ils sont 2 juin à séville et certains à
l'apathie j'ai rencontré quelques
parents cet après midi c'est un saint
bruno dhont cette mère de famille de
trois enfants qui m'a dit qu'ils avaient
vraiment vécu des moments d'angoissé
imaginé avec des enfants la maison elle
qui travaille est obligé de rester à la
maison faire des compromis avec son mari
et elle m'a dit aussi qu'elle n'en
revenait pas de l'attitude de la
ministre de la famille je pense que la
ministre de la famille et se pose est de
soutenir toutes les familles au québec
et c'est parce qu'on a senti pas du tout
là c'est vraiment se mettre de mettre
des bâtons dans les roues dans toutes
les familles dans sa peau était une
histoire qui était tout rose puis c'est
ce que on apprécie pour n'est vraiment
content et soulagé de cette décision là
évidemment patrice cette garderie
évidemment on est soulagés ici les
parents aussi dans la région à saint
bruno
alors cette garderie doit ouvrir ses
portes dès la semaine prochaine on parle
de lundi prochain et c'est le cas sans
doute pour des dizaines d'autres
nouvelles gares donner au québec qui
pourront maintenant avec l'émission des
permis qui pourront maintenant ouvrir
leur porte donc
au cours des prochains jours mais voilà
merci à jacques nous appris à voir